on va rester dans le domaine musical
pour s'intéresser au scarabé et à sa
programmation mais avant ça je vous
propose juste d'écouter Jacques Pornon
que nous avons rencontré pour le théâtre
de Saint-Quentin ainsi que Joël Dupuis
pour Montini qui nous parle tous les
deux respectivement de leur
programmation programmation relativement
diversifiée qui s'adresse à tout public
monsieur le maire a souhaité que l'on
développe au niveau des spectacles la
régularité c'est-à-dire que il y a
certains spectacles qui se feront sur
deux représentant tion afin de répondre
un peu à l'attente du public c'est aussi
bien du classique de l'humour du blues
euh du théâtre d'humour du théâtre
classique du théâtre contemporain de la
danse contemporaine de la danse aussi
avec les balets Nationales de Pologne
donc la volonté de de la ville de
Montini c'est vraiment de s'adresser à
tous les publics petit grand de toutes
les sensibilités artistiques sans
oublier les temps forts très très
apprécié des spectacles jeunes public
qui sont très attendus puisque nous
avons une représentation en journée pour
les scolaires et puis le soir en
représentation familiale cette nouvelle
programmation elle a le je pense le
mérite de d'être éclectique d'être
ouverte puisquil y a du cirque il y a de
la danse il a des spectacles jeun public
il y a de la musique il y a du théâtre
il y a de la poésie la programmation
elle a à la fois une dimension festive
une dimension aussi de de de
connaissance de découverte de du plaisir
on va dire de la de la rencontre et de
la
nouveauté alors retour maintenant au
scarabé Samuel Denis la programmation
cette année sera donc musicale mais pas
que un deux exceptions près je crois
voilà on reprend la la ligne des années
précédentes c'està-dire une
programmation comme vous dites quasiment
exclusivement musicale et dans ce
créneau musical principalement chanson
chanson
française on parle on dit deux mots sur
les exceptions d'abord ou sur Oui
allons-y de exception de quoi s'agit-il
donc les deux exceptions il en avait une
qu'on avait tous les ans avec en
partenariat avec la fête du compte du
réseau des médiiaathèques ou comme il y
a eu un petit une année
deement en fait pas eu sur la dernière
saison donc là on reprend le parten le
partenariat avec la fête du compte
raconte-moi une histoire ou avec un
jeune public qui s'appelle Patrice ca
sur un spectacle qui s'appelle contou
donc des compes traditionnel africain
revisité en version sou F très énergique
on fera un travail avec des scolaires en
amont pendant un trimestre com on fait
tous les tous les jeunes publics ont
fait un travail en amont avec des
scolaires et class à pque à proet
artistique et culturel donc là on voit
bien les liens entre les uns et les
autres chacune chaque commune chaque
salle on sent qu'il y a il y a vraiment
un un travail de fond autour des des des
scolaires autour du jeune public il y a
un projet porté par la communauté
d'agglomération et on le ressent chez
chacun de vous il y a cette cette
plaquette jeune public qu'on qu'on va
dire qu'on qu'on édite ensemble c'est l'
GL qui
qu' l'imprime mais c'est La La La
Réunion en fait de toutes les
programmations publiqu de toutes les
structures de la gllo et ça date depuis
déjà ça va être la 5e saison qu'on fait
ça donc c'est très pratique pour les
familles d'avoir ENF pour les familles
et pour les écoles et les centres de
loisir enfin tout ce qui touche au jeune
public d'avoir cette plaquette il y a
plein d'endroits quand je leur dis nous
on a ça chez nous mais c'est c'est un
super boutil et donc voilà et donc pour
revenir sur la fête du compte donc on a
rapatrice ca et aussi Isabelle ticier
une navigatrice une ancienne navigatrice
sportive qui fait des comptes sur la mer
d'accord je suis allé la voir sur une
péniche à Paris je me suis laissé
envoûter donc je je me suis dit fallait
qu' j'essaie d'envoûter mon mon public
aussi avec ça et puis l'autre exception
l'autre entorse enfin pas une entorse
l'autre entorse on l'a fait en
partenariat avec Sabine ici présente oui
alors avec une pièce de théâtre donc de
Nadir youullin donc qui a déjà fait ses
armes dans la vidéo mais au niveau du du
spectacle vivant c'est une première pour
lui donc c'est un jeune originaire de La
Verrière on dire de l'agglomération
voilà et donc qui se lance sur une sur
une pièce de théâtre qui va s'appeler
toupac Chacour rouyem pour un tog de
légende donc
en sur la la la vie la vie on va dire la
vie et la mort d'un d'un célèbre rappeur
américain une figure emblématique du rap
américain et là aussi on est dans le
cadre d'un projet commun avec
l'agglomération hein c'est ça Sabine
cossin alors oui c'est-à-dire que du
coup cette création qui se passe de
toupac à La Verrière pour lequel le
prisme à laquelle il participe il rentre
dans le cadre de d'un projet qui est
partagé qui s'appelle pulsation urbaine
qui est très large qui va surtout
l'ensemble des communes la ferme de
bébas la meruris à trap enfin bon il y a
un bon nombre et à l'intérieur des
Pulsations Urbaines cette année il y a
un événement à partentière qui est de
fêter les 30 ans du hip hop parce que
c'est le patrimoine ça démarrera sur les
journées du patrimoine puisque le thème
du journées du patrimoinees son un
patrimoine immatériel et c'est vrai que
l'histoire de Saint-Quentin en Eveline
et ben c'est l'histoire de la naissance
de la compagnie des Black blomber qui
est la première des compagnies de Hipop
danse en France le hip hop a 40 ans aux
États-Unis mais il en a 30 en France
enfin il en aura 30 en France en il fait
leur 30 ans voilà c'est ça donc du coup
c'était intéressant autour de de cet
acte de création des B3 il y a une
trentaine d'années ben de montrer ce que
le hip hop aujourd'hui donc dans ce
c'est un mouvement aussi bien en musique
donc sur le rap que sur la danse pouvait
refléter aujourd'hui 30 ans après donc
on a des premières générations comme
sont les BL blambur donc ça je sais
qu'ils seront à la merie bien sûr on a
les tout de suite derrière 2e génération
avec les mouran merzuki kfig et les
caderatou qui seront Mourad merzuki sera
à la scè nationale caderatou sera sur
une carte blanche au prisme et avec la
jeune génération c'estàdire avec des
nouveaux styles de hip hop le Crump qui
est une danse très particulière avec une
intensité très forte et puis les femmes
dans le Hip Hop alors on va refaire une
petite boucle puisque c'est comme ça que
vous avez fait votre plateau et ben oui
parce que les femmes sont assez peu
présentes dans le dans le hiphop on
comprend bien pourquoi c'est culturel
elle alors que c'est pas physique et par
contre elle commence à émerger depuis un
certain nombre d'années notamment nous
on aura dans la carte blanche de Cader
et c'est ce qu'il a souhaité avoir un
Nguyen qui a été d'ailleurs une des
danseuses de la compagnie black bomber
donc les les choses évoluent les choses
évoluent bien heureusement voilà vous
avez présenté des directeurs mais il y a
une directrice et tris directeurs c'est
vrai alors Samuel Denis pour revenir à
votre programmation cette fois-ci
musical j'ai envie de connaître comment
comment vous constiuez comment vous
voilà cette programmation vous la
construiez comment exactement donc une
programmation essentiellement chanson ça
j'ai déjà dit quelques incursions
musique du monde qui nous rapprochent
dans CEAD de la
Merise et puis des artistes étrangers
jeis entendis Sabine parler d'artistes
étrangers je me suis dit ti oui c'est
vrai cette année on en a quatre ce qui
est beaucoup pour nous on est plutôt sur
la chanson française là on a on a un
artiste québécois on a un artiste cubain
on a des Irlandais pour fêter la
saint-patrique parce qu'il rien n des
Irlandais les vrais irlandais pour la
saint-patrique et on a un groupe
marocain aussi am bouchnac au mois
d'avril mais pour ce qui est donc donc
de du de l'essentiel de la programmation
chanson on aura quelques tes d'affiches
oui on peut dire quelques nom il y aura
Kent piano voie au mois de décembre il y
aura volo et loï Lantoine au mois de
mai il y aura une tête d'affiche al pour
certains une grosse blague pour d'autres
ah bon mais j'assume totalement on va
faire le le retour sur scène d'mer foot
beat au mois de février donc voilà une
soirée une soirée absolument pas
sérieuse mais on a le droit aussi une
fois par faire des
même si on faisait trois fois par an il
y aurait rien de bien grave à faire des
soirées pas sérieuses euh voilà donc moi
je vais en septembre au festival du
chînon manquant qui se qui semble
désormais se poser à l'aval donc au mois
de septembre ensuite j'écume les salles
de spectacle d'île-defance et vous
piochez comme ça voilà je vais voir une
un spectacle ou deux spectacles par
semaine et je clôture à leur chante à
motoban au mois de mai alors est-ce
qu'on peut dire que que la scène du
scarabé c'est à la fois peut-être un
trempelin pour ces jeunes artistes et en
même temp une scène découverte du coup
pour pour le public oui puisqueen dehors
des noms qu'on a cité comme Kmer fobit
ou volantoine les autres sont moins
connu du grand public voire quasiment
absent des médias nationaux ou voire
même
régionaux l'idée c'est de moi j'ai
ressenti quelque chose voir ces gens-l
qui disent quelque
chose pas forcément de manière engagée
mais ça peut être aussi sous forme
poétique sous forme moristique ou
effectivement des textes plus plus
engagés on et l'envie de faire parti ça
au public donc les gens commencent
effectivement à venir au scarabé les
yeux fermés en disant voilà on on va
découvrir on y va pour et ils vous font
confiance
ouais ou oui
je ça porte ses fruits doucement très
bien alors moi je vous propose avant de
de passer à un sujet d'actualité un peu
de réflexion vous l'aviez préparé il y a
pas il y aura pas de surprise je vous
propose déjà aussi qu'on écoute les
représentants à la culture des villes de
maniléamo et euh pardon deux voisins qui
tous deux aussi nous parlent de leur
programmation
entre novembre et janvier nous aurons
des spectacles destinés au jeune public
et en particulier en novembre un
spectacle professionnel qui s'appelle
pluie en coopération avec les autres
villes de l'agglomération c'est un
spectacle qui va tourner sur plusieurs
villes et c'est vrai que c'est le
travail entre nos différentes villes le
travail des services culturels entre nos
différentes villes qui nous permettent
d'accueillir maintenant depuis l'année
dernière déjà des spectacles
professionnels de qualité à destination
des des jeunes publics cette
programmation 2013 va être un grand
moment du rock and roll parce que on va
avoir énormément de nouveautés
énormément aussi d'action culturell pour
les manicois dans la ville et des petits
changements des petits changements
d'importance notamment dans le domaine
du cinéma où on va on faisait jusqu'à
présent une semaine du cinéma là on va
faire plusieurs nuit du cinéma en
collaboration une forte collaboration
avec le lycée de Villarois on a des
collabor tion avec la Maison de la
poésie le théâtre de
Saint-Quentin alors cette semaine
démarrait le baccalauréat et en Guyane
le sujet de philosophie était la culture
nous rend-t-elle plus libre alors je
vous pose la question à chacun en deux
mots Sabine cossin quel est votre
ressenti qu une piste de réflexion sur
sur ce sujet de philo oui par rapport au
travail que peut-être un lieu comme le
prix centre de développement artistique
de Saint-Quentin en Yveline c'est
peut-être donc ce travail de médiation
de mettre les artistes en contact avec
la population les habitants de
Saint-Quentin le fait de les rencontrer
de créer avec eux de pratiquer va
forcément favoriser le développement de
l'individu sa réflexion dans son corps
dans son attitude dans l'altérité
vis-à-vis des autres et et forcément
liberté tout à fait Claude robinski bon
j a un peu réfléchi et de peur d'être
trop long on va faire court ah
dites-nous alors de quoi s'agit-il voilà
c'est c'est le c'est l'affiche de de la
saison ouais ENF donc on voit je je sais
je peux vous prendre
pardon je vais la montrer en fait voilà
c'est un oiseau
euh qui a une cage au-udessus de sa tête
et cet oiseau est libre il s'est libéré
libre dans sa tête en venant en venant à
la meurise ou ou au prisqueès bien voilà
voil Samuel Denis quel est votre
sentiment sur la culture ne rend-elle
plus libre oh plein de sentiments non
c'est c'est essentiellement un Lian de
de l'humain de l'humanité alors je je
reprécise qu'on est dans la culture au
sens artistique et pas anthropologique
ni sociologique et donc nous pour nous
dans l'occurrence le spectacle vivant
qui pour moi c'est un facteur d'émotion
ressenti d'émotions partagées de
convivialité c'est bien aussi et donc de
oui on va dire de un épanouissement
personnel qui qui amène forcément en
additionnant tous ces épanouissements
personnels un enrichissement collectif
meilleure connaissance de l'autre alors
est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est ça la
liberté en tout cas c'est
une c'est une ouverture vers d'autres
horizons et et ça ne peut faire tourner
le monde que dans un meilleur sens après
ce que ça amène la liberté c'est on va
laisser ça au terminal de Guam nous
écouterons leur réponse en effet alors
Johann Lavabre pour vous la culture la
liberté voilà est-ce que tout ça je
dirais c'est lié en tout cas la culture
peut-être un instrument
d'émancipation ça veut pas dire
forcément que que la culture libère tout
le temps la culture peut aussi être un
outil de propagande mais oui jefin en
tout cas je crois que la culture telle
que nous la concevons ici telle que nous
nous en faisons la la promotion est un
instrument d'émancipation en tout cas
elle le doit c'est certain d'accord en
tout cas on a bien
comprisau travers de de ces échanges
échanges pardon vous êtes chacun
complémentaire vous apportez des choses
nouvelles sur sur le territoire sa an
iveline est riche est riche
culturellement et tout ça c'est grâce à
vous donc on vous en remercie voilà
alors ce 78 culture et présent terminé
merci de nous avoir suivi sur TVfil à
très
[Musique]
bientôt